I will be going bet my name return path
and welcome back suit us how you doing
Jeff how you doing great it's been a
while since our last vendor booth this
game is the relationship cut I don't
[ __ ] know what this game is
soundlessly we're gonna be gonzalez
Gonzalo I'm sorry
let's go nah not Greg or Gonzalo let's
do this I got the filly difficult a game
like slender like I do every once in a
while I will never [ __ ] complete it
Gonzales had Gonzalo
as an app and what Oh bad why don't they
oh there we go
you bet hey I thought I heard someone
out here great to see you gimme kiss Wow
yeah it's beautiful to be here well come
on in now where where is that lady the
back of the ice no no your we are yes
how are you I am so happy all right
no I guess you're right I guess you're
right don't touch me don't touch me bro
don't touch me bro we're just the rises
we adjust all right you know not going
anyway [ __ ] up I'm taking this dojo
don't come near me what the game well at
least I have my spider-man thing I don't
need you Gonzales
what the [ __ ] all right let's do another
one just for funsies because that was
kind of short I asked you in a second
breath all right let's see if we can
solve this you said our dad I'm supposed
to be yeah it's like listened to trip
you menstruation girl come on open solo
hey how's good no hard feelings about
before right man yeah this is about two
minutes ago
you look great thanks man are you
hitting on me I love that switch right
all right really great to see you thanks
bro
thanks the lodge man is nice I don't
know your buddies moving Oh grace now
the [ __ ] alright I'll just help myself
with some alcohol yeah white wine
purposes red wine for real Italian man
it's gonna lock me in jail I thought you
might like this photo I just put out
from our recent trip to Italy alright
let's watch it it's a beautiful picture
of the Italian Commerce I am pretty much
right now that's pretty good hey anybody
join me on the couch if you like oh I
think your wife is hitting on me
Gonzalo yeah what does this picture make
you know what oh man ah oh yeah I
remember that oh man oh man tricky yeah
that's a good one trip not gonna bore
you with the steering track romantic
weekend great a dame all right grace
come here let's have some wine I'm gonna
fix us some drinks me and grace instead
of cocktail making accessory have a zip
girl
well betting it up thank you like this
grace I've got the perfect bottle of
it's going up here now is grace just
such a tired drink crazy
we went wine taste out of imported
drinking glasses Oh son
fancy maybe you're on my side hahaha so
drinks
yep how does a martini sound how does
the penis out any worse no don't throw
me out geez just a joke calm your tits
what it's funny right ha ha penis dings
I don't even exist do they all right
surprised me going there for a second
yeah I'm a funny dude man
come on it's not helping things for you
to say that yah
what no no don't kick me out we're all
friends here you're not what yeah not
afraid to say anything nope push our
little buttons what button no trip how
about a manly kiss yeah
how about it man come here you see that
[ __ ] trip great hello I know you've got
to leave fine
I don't want to stay with you anyway
throwing with your chin man looks like
it'll be fine you should just go such a
[ __ ] alright I think that'll have to be
it for my facade experience for today
hope you bros enjoyed like and favorite
if you did subscribe comatose today and
I'll see you next episode
oh boy ah huh make sounds for us I know
you well
[Music]
what the hell twins - better dressed up
ah I don't want to twist your nipples
but jump out at you and quacks but what
will happen if I don't don't worry about
it